recently we started a new site conan
xxx all right
so far we have debuted two conan xxx
videos on the site one girl 20 pencils
that was pretty amazing
and one guy two bowls
featuring our own andy richter eating
two bowls of soup now
i i have regrets yeah
[Laughter]
never seen you so filled with shame well
or soup well tonight
tonight we've got another conan xxx
video to show you it's called please do
the crossword
with my wife
enjoy it
alright thanks for coming by and doing
this
uh
what are your names
i'm jose laurie jose and laurie okay
how long have you been married
about two years about two years okay we
like to do
crosswords together um yeah do the
proper puzzle together yeah yeah today
though
i understand that you have a bit of a
request
and that is that you would like
jose to watch you do a crossword puzzle
with another
something that you've been meaning to
try
yeah
i mean if it makes laurie happy we'd
like you to meet someone laurie uh dion
why don't you come on in here
laura this is dionne
i'm good thank you
jose why don't you scoot on over a
little bit there
give them give them some room so they
can do the crossword
hey jose why don't you move on over to
the stool uh next to the
spray you guys just take the center of
the couch there terrific
you might like me
nah i brought some okay
all right well uh
i'm just gonna shut up now and i'm gonna
let the two of you do that crossword
puzzle and jose just sit back and relax
and enjoy the show all right
[Music]
engagement 48 across the original could
be a ring right
a ring it would be rain yeah
you've done this before haven't you
pretty
pretty mature
again this is a uh this is a real site
so go check it out at conan dot triple x
you